Oprah Winfrey celebrates her b-day In
Style With a Little Help from Kim
Kardashian and Jennifer Lopez it just
turned out to be something really
magical the media Mogul rang in her 69th
birthday on Saturday at a star-studded
bash to commemorate the 25th anniversary
of the beauty brand Anastasia Beverly
Hills where she was seated next to Kim
and JLo it's really fun to see during
the festivities Lydia was presented with
a gorgeous cake for her special day so I
get so excited about it and on Sunday
Oprah's actual birthday Kim Kardashian
shared this snap with the birthday girl
writing happy birthday Oprah Sharon
Stone said it best last night toasting
to you that you mean the world to the
world happy birthday I don't know how
you're gonna top that also in attendance
at the fancy Soiree JLo who showed off
her glitzy party attire in the this clip
and posed it up for a few selfies with
Kim and the TV icon it's a beautiful
moment Sophia Vergara Priyanka Chopra
Jessica Alba Heidi Klum and Rita Wilson
were also there cuddling up for this
epic snap my motto is go big or go home
but the celebration didn't stop there on
Sunday Oprah's bestie Gail King gave a
special shout out to her BFF writing on
Instagram happy everything to the girl
who lives her best life every day and
does what she can to help everybody else
do the same
this friend has always wanted more for
me than I ever wanted for myself the
birthday girl also took a moment to
reflect on the past year writing on her
website that it's a reward to be turning
69 and to be strong and healthy that's
what growing up is all about that's what
evolving is all about
the birthday you get
or the beginning of your finest hours I
choose the latter and hope that you do
too because each trip around the Sun
gives us with a new beginning
[Music]
thank you